Google said good luck Google said good
luck 3 2 y and everyone welcome to
simulation we have a very special
episode today we are gonna be talking
about being a mystic being a yogi we're
going to talk about humanitarian goals
we are going to unpack the importance of
mastering our own consciousness and
mastering our life we have a very
special guest calling in from Skype from
Los Angeles not eg hello thank you for
taking that moment to ground me on that
excitement I really appreciate it thanks
for coming on to our show we greatly
appreciate it thank you
it's an online wonderful be here we are
very big fans of your work and the work
of spiritual development in general so
why don't you teach us a bit about how
you got involved in spiritual work
yourself yes I think a long time or each
of us to wake up and in mind it was I
was running a successful business and it
struck me that I was going to die
collapse is going to collapse and there
was that unseen there was that that
aspect of death which wasn't really
anything other than pain
and that's how I felt it it was like a
huge nightmare to happen and then my you
know then it happened in the mystical
way where that day when I felt I needed
to source connect the most and I did not
know how to that's the day when I got a
knock on the door and when I opened the
door that was my guru for the first time
I'm meeting him he had to keep that the
first time he's meeting me and he comes
in and tells me you got that coming for
you God Silva has sent me to take you
would you like to come with me I'm gonna
take you to the fire to Kalahasti
which is far away he said would you like
to come and I said I've been waiting for
you all my life I'm all yours
let's go and so he took me through my
death journey and one thing which was
spectacular which I hold on to is that
when he was taking me through my death
it was several layers of death several
deaths in several lifetimes and deep
inside me I felt it like an embryo a
blue color embryo that was peaceful that
I that I knew was God that was calm that
was tranquil that literally held all the
realities within if the witness to all
my deaths it was the little business to
my rebirth into and then slowly that
blue light which was so inside me became
bigger and bigger and bigger and then
soon I realized that was me and when I
came back into the human realities
I couldn't smoke cigarettes anymore I
couldn't I used love haha I used love
drinking but not I wasn't a drink I
wasn't an alcoholic but I couldn't drink
anymore
something in me had completely and now
what I experienced was the
Ian Seymour the shear state of joy shear
state of happiness and that happiness
came from feeling I would liberated
feeling I was free
and feeling I was not really a mess born
I was a lady willing and I wanted more
of that I wanted more of that beingness
that I experienced so the next few years
were the journey within myself through
solitude through caves through the sit
down wilderness and especially with the
grace of my gurus who took me through my
inner journey went deeper and deeper
realizing I was awakening to my own
wholeness and that wholeness was what I
could worshiping through all the shrines
and temples and then came the next I
would say no important aspect of my
realization and that was why am I here
what I here to do and the standing that
my body and might be heinous as a helper
yes it's come and I see now it's my
response and what is it
and so this is my oh wow
okay so a lot to unpack there first of
all I love how you describe it as shelf
life I love how you described a shelf
life it's very important to realize that
we will die and that it's time for us to
unleash our full potential our full
divinity
onto this planet and that's what we can
do in our short time that we have here
and I like how you went through that
process of of discovering that and then
now sharing it now what are maybe the
strategies that people can take into
their lives as habits to unlock their
full potential
yes when we understand the other spirit
having the human experience we
understand that business experience in
fact that time is meditation so it vital
of all of us meditated connect source
connecting and that source can be called
void and because God can be called
absolute can be called infinity but the
moment we are connecting to source now
we are beginning to understand we are
that spirit experiencing the body
experiencing the mind and more important
than experiencing it then the
experiences beginning to unravel the
potential of the mind itself now for
most of us our mind itself is the limit
we are caught in a package of karma we
are caught in the entrapment of memories
we also thought in terms of the limited
nature of our five senses the moment we
awaken to being the spirit we start
opening the extra powers each one of us
have every one of us have something
incredibly special now how does that
happen when we meditate we begin to
start seeing the big picture we come to
the knowing
and when we come to the knowing now we
have we are empowered by the power of
inspiration and when we are empowered by
the power of inspiration and knowing we
begin to step into the next layer of our
potential I would rather say the next
reality which is the state of Toria the
yogic state of mind this yogic state of
mind is the same state of mind that were
that Albert Einstein room a Mahatma
Gandhi all the Masters who move the
frontiers of humanity had this empowers
plate of primary they talking state of
mind altering the moment we step into
the state of torreón now we are going to
which are able to go beyond the limits
of the body that is like hunger Heatley
cold limits of the mind that this
fatigue sleep we go beyond that and now
we are tapping in the greater potential
that is within ourselves that is very
much like an eagle that can see the big
picture it doesn't just apply but cannot
slide it but also I can breathe into
focus that's specific and the third
dimension bring in the power of my
talent so in these three the power of
focus the ability to see the ability of
knowing and and passion along with the
vitality of energy comes into play we
become natural leaders we simply do and
when we keep doing the world follows us
so this is the potential in every one of
us and this potentials obtained happens
at the most odd times for instance when
Nelson Mandela was locked up Mahatma
Gandhi who locked up that's when they
could unlock this potential
now in circumstances like us in the
regular world when we do power and
meditate
if we know that ultimately became plain
to layer the honey that we taste as
bliss after yoga now in the honey pot
itself consciousness itself and when we
be paid consciousness itself everything
is possible we see way before or
practically painless zone now when is a
different time
it means we created the most perfect
realities thought through reality is
bridged this is the benefits of yoga I
would say this is yogam the objective of
yoga to attain that of conscious in
consciousness itself the I just so much
began to for us to absorb and and then
go on I I love the wisdom here okay so
maybe one of the things that I think was
really interesting was that this this
sort of the the divinity that we each
have within us being unleashed
to its fullest if we do this process of
meditation we do this process of
understanding ourselves and
understanding the short time that we
have here that our spirit though is
living through this body and through
these senses and that we can go past
that and that going past that that that
transcendence that process of
transcending the biological system and
the limits and perception that that that
and then building something of of use of
utility into our world that's that is
that is exciting to do every single day
after day that we really enjoy that
that that at the towards at the end of
that process then that's when we think
to ourselves amazing I was fulfilled and
I am fulfilled and then that is would
you say then that that is that is one of
the definitions of a fulfillment or a
meaningful life then if we the moment we
wake up call highest purpose we know now
we are at a power of its bridge when we
inspire the universe collaborate with us
we are able to summon a unique genius we
are like a painter painting stepping
into timelessness and painting itself is
time we begin to start reworking life
from core harmony and what we are
experiencing within as koha mandated
manifests itself to the form of a
blissful blissful body in other words a
yogi body is that of love bliss reality
is to now become abundant reality has
become that of harmony core harmony
reality is break through the boundaries
what kicks in is the extra senses that's
why we say we have the five senses and
when we wake up the sixth sense happens
so the six pointed star for instance
depicts the cosmic child within each one
of us the male and the female coming
together infinity and the finish coming
together timelessness of time coming
together the moment that wakes up the
cosmic we are the calm and child and now
I the cosmic child we are empowered with
a mind that is not just a mind - the
super mind that also is able to see the
past present and future now these are
positives
now so this is the extra powers that
come but we do not seek it
most important in our meditation is
understanding that if we are wanting to
be still you cannot force yourself to be
still
we can try become instead you can become
the dance and become the dancer and when
you become the dance and the dancer
stillness naturally happens in other
words when you are the inspired state of
doing you are in reality meditating when
you are in a cave or when you are in a
meditation mode or when you are going
into yourself if you go into the states
of your innermost dance of joy and
master that joy you are mastering
consciousness and in that process life
itself is mastered it's a yeah this is
the the dance between my experience and
my conch my consciousness my experience
my fulfillment my drive my cosmic my
cosmic divinity that I was blessed
through unlocking my my potential
through going past my senses
transcending you said this was really
beautiful to me you said that every
single child of the cosmos has their own
fullest potential
has their own ability to unlock
themselves fully we just we just have to
design a better social fabric that
enables more people to fully maximize
themselves I would say it's a
respectable the social society it
doesn't matter at all it just matters
that each one of us understand that if
we want to tap into a greater potential
source connect meditate that's the first
step and then we begin to start
experiencing the expanded consciousness
now with expanded consciousness come to
the source fulness and it also along
with that comes the energy fields of
yoga the energy field of yoga moves
we have entities at a much faster pace
now for instance when we breathe we all
have a number of breaths implant of you
know as as living being impressive
limited account of breath is limited but
within each breath there is eternity we
begin to tap into that eternity within
each breath and now experiences
experience enhances our life our life
realities itself so all it takes is for
each of us individually to understand
that when you saw us connect you are
also redefining the 24-hour cycle we are
whether we like it or not prisoners of
time we wake up in the morning and then
it's time to get to bed at night then we
are the prisoners of the mind five times
a day without us knowing it
unconsciously a breath flips to the
right those are the times we are very
inspired check every sunset moment which
side the job
are you breathing from it would normally
be from the right the time when you
inspired check to the time when you're
very very tired and you're sleepy the
breath of the flip to the left that also
means that the time that you're not
inspired there's a greater chance of you
being depressed so this is being the
prisoner of the mind so the prison of
the mind and prisoner of time and then
come the prisoner of energy to when you
inspire you have all they're not even
you're not inspire you do not have
energy the vitality part is missing so
all this these limits are in the moment
broken free the moment we've climbed up
I would say it like de mine is a rooftop
it's like climbing up a mountain and and
sitting from the peak and looking at
everything everything looks so beautiful
even a sewer below on the ground looks
beautiful from above you are seeing the
great grand picture
now you're able to summon the energy is
necessary to move and the first step I
would say is make a lamp once a day this
is between us and source when you later
lamp outside yourself in reality you're
writing a map inside yourself and that
is most important the inner most sacred
fire
now this innermost sacred fire is a
concept it's a very miss it's a mystical
concept but it is a very practical
concept and this practical concept of
being a Yogi's is if your inner fire is
lit you are a yogi now what does that
mean this means that at all times there
is a dance going on inside you at all
time you are tending that you know most
fire through every breath so every
breath is taken with awareness and that
awareness produces not thought alone
that awareness produces wisdom and that
wisdom itself guides so that inner fire
is something like it's called the tapas
energy the power of the bus now my one
of us one of my guru I are sad for a
total of 27 years drinking one cup of
milk a day get gone beyond sleeping he
was at a place of to Rio but several
layers as supposed to be eighteen states
of Tahrir he was on one of the higher
level the torii away did not need to be
sustained anymore with food it now that
energy is powerful because anyone coming
into proximity may not talk to him in a
moment they would receive His blessing
then when they go home they've got a
part of him that part of him was
actually that inner fire and that was
tough us in the movie Superman if you've
seen it he loses his girlfriend in a
landslide and he goes counterclockwise
around around the globe around the earth
to bring his girlfriend back to life
what he was trying to demo
for what this is how we might explain
the power of us that every reality of
yours can be twisted and turned and
moved together and this concept of being
able to twist and turn everything
together really means you are now in the
state of joy and dance and when you want
the state of joy and dance you now you
have the power to create discipline and
you are disciplined enough to want it
forward to disciplined enough to have it
more so yes we we do when we experience
steps of joy this is I wanna I want to
say that this is so good and I know
you're going and it's so good but I
gotta say on the on the way just to make
sure we highlight these really billion
things that are coming out this sort of
the first pillar is meditation so we we
tune in word and we notice that the
breath does something so magnificent it
just does at least something so
magnificent that's first we don't need
to label it with words we can just feel
what it feels like first and so we do
that and then we see okay now that I
took those breaths what happened to my
body could it be possible like you said
this was very interesting that by taking
in that deep long breath you can almost
feel eternity in one moment in time that
was so interesting when you said that
then it doesn't feel like the biological
clock is ticking and ticking and ticking
but we're just we're finding eternity in
every breath and every moment and then
you mentioned this I thought this was
really important too you mentioned that
every day if we wake up and we just
light the flame the candle the lamp
within us to live life in that sense in
this way of pure vitality towards you
like the lamp outside us
outside ourselves just to manifest what
the outside inside ourselves it's like a
daily ritual for our homes I love it I
love it and then it reminds us oh I'm
gonna light it inside as well out in
okay and then you know we were we were
we kind of have been talking about this
for now but you know you're in LA we're
in Silicon Valley there's lots of people
in New York and Hong Kong and London and
Cape Town in so many different places
across the earth that are building
things they're working on companies
businesses doing things like making more
electricity making more food and water
making better systems for Humanity and
making better technology all this stuff
now what is maybe a you know a
recommendation because you've been
talking about it so far and it's been
really interesting but this path that
entrepreneurs and scientists are on
today what would be a good like piece of
advice as you said meditate as maybe you
pillar number one what would be another
good pillar or these pieces of advice
for people that are on their journey to
make being really good impact on the
world
okay know that when you say meditation
we are talking about a meditative mind
and that meditative mind is very much
like most of okay let's reread less
rework those most humans meditate
exclusively when they are making love
now when there is lovemaking happening
everything else is forgotten only it's
only the state of joy and then that
state of joy is in a moment now if that
state of joy was all the time
now that's meditation when you meditate
you're connecting to that amazing states
of joy at all times
now there is an energy field going on
within the vast void there's a dancer
and that's within ourselves within the
vast absolute entity of nothingness and
everything there we are
within dancing not that in the vibratory
field and that vibrates a field is able
to tune into the to tune into or to the
infinite intelligence that is necessary
and needed it so this is one dimensional
on a very practical note write your
thoughts under linton's as six for
instance you have a great idea try to
work the thought and six different
dimensions that brings into mana things
that into manifestation remember that eg
quick-quick thought for you on this on
this what we've been just discussing
okay can we unpack the difference
between the meditative mind and just
maybe meditation in general and there
are so many different ways that people
perceive and experience meditation so
maybe in this case of what you know what
you and I were talking a little bit
about before the show I think this is
important the idea of meditation of
something like of a poss and a
meditation where you observe your
respiration through your nose and you
observe your respiration through your
nose and every time a thought comes to
your mind you just bring your attention
back to your nose and continue
respiration and then you feel sensation
and so now what's you know is a
meditative mind you can carry throughout
your day you can be on the crazy bus or
the crazy restaurant very loud very loud
but you can keep a meditative mind can
expand about this more a little bit for
us
it's very it's it's vital that we see
this you know we understand this
perspective of meditation
now the rapacity meditation is beautiful
because it brings you to the objective
of meditation which is having a pristine
mind that does not have thoughts going
on and allowing us to connect to our
source without the mind playing its part
but the external world has too many
things going on what if a major reality
of a year because it's stress was
happening and you try to go into the
state of no thought it is not going to
work as well but instead let's look into
the wholeness of everything there is the
reality going on and there is the mind
what if we wished pilling in an inner
dimension that took care of the reality
to around us that we are truly
stress-free because we create we are
creating a reality of peace itself we
are transforming the reality itself
while meditating we really know that
we're not escaping anywhere but we are
actually transforming the world from
inside out now how does that happen
this happens when when we awaken to the
innermost dance and that's why in our
tradition instances or even the Tibetan
tantric tradition the mantra is
important when you receive the mantra
and you go on chanting now your mind is
pointed out to a particular place and
that which is pointed to becomes the
mind that which you think about we
become so now when you step into a
mantra let's assume that the Taurus all
that nature the goddess now becomes us
we so the mantra
guides us towards the meditative MA
and so it's it's a practice of us
calling our own attention towards that
and that's why if it becomes a mantra a
daily practice we're calling that forth
exactly exactly now let's assume in
reality you do have a problem we cannot
run away saying hey I'd rather have a
mind that is not perturbed by that
mirror but that reality not easy I just
want to also make sure that we are
telling people if this is true if you
can tell me what you think about this
but even doing something as simple as
entering Child's Pose yogic position at
9:00 a.m. or 11 a.m. or whenever
throughout the day is just that good
grounding point and it can turn on your
meditative mind is that right it is
you've got to see it like this that
every breath of ours we are knowing
where we are breathing from and where we
are breathing to that awareness of every
breath enables us to slowly step into
the vortex of being the light itself yes
now when we are the light we know that
all of all the Masters serve serve that
light what if all the Masters service by
giving us thought which is wisdom
now this component is the mystical
component where we are saying be the
light and be served by like that all the
Masters that's one dimension of it but
like how you just said that all seven
and a half billion of us are then
masters and we all unleash the light
within us and then that would be a build
a prosperous world that's that's good
yeah it is no let's take it to another
component which is you now that you have
a pristine mind that is sourced
connecting itself at
every breath now comes our own in a
potential that begins to start shining
the moment we realized oh my god this is
where I am passionate about this is what
I am doing from my heart now all of the
cities came and the city really need the
extra power means that which each one of
us have already been given so now not
only are we working with the supermind
we are also working with an energy field
that way beyond the human we have a new
evaporate for that because what does it
actually mean to work with the energy
field beyond the human or I know where
we've been talking about that but what
does it mean to have the spiritual force
behind this physical body and then are
when we have our meditative mind are we
tapping into that spiritual force more
than the physical body and we're
transcending the physical body to that
spiritual force when were when we're
meditating what does what does that look
like what does that feel like
see I related to Mahatma Gandhi story
that when he was there was a time when
everything seemed to have failed for him
he really thought it will not be able to
attain its a attain its attained its
independence and there was a time when
he was in the wilderness political
wilderness and he continued with having
his source connectivity every day more
rigorously than ever and at that time of
utter disappointment that for a long
period of time if we do not read in
history books about the globe but the
long period of time and he was in
wilderness at that time he wakes up it
was like the spirit in him seeing
something so amazing to happen that
didn't sound really like a major reality
it was the salt much we visualize that
he is going to get the get to making the
salt to challenge the British Empire and
that actually started the real
revolution of India towards independence
and it became unstoppable so he writes
you know I saw them I had a prophetic
vision and I see it and now I know
nothing will stop us and that galvanized
the entire nation to move so coming back
this is this this is within each one of
us that week set up to sing oh my god
this is where we are this is what we
need to do and this is how we need to do
it and everything then aligns itself it
it's it's LeGrande our producer director
says this a lot about us just becoming
better humans and if we figure out how
to each become a better human the
collective becomes better and then we
can unlock our our complete maximum
potential together I want to make sure
that we that we touch on these so
mastery of consciousness let's maybe
talk about the book as well for a bit
what are some of the key thesis from the
book consciousness gives birth to
thought the higher the consciousness
thought is wisdom and that wisdom
creates reality so if we attain
consciousness everything around us from
life to relationship to health to
everything else takes care of itself so
this is one part one component of that
the other component is when I was doing
my pilgrim and over the time in my life
when I realized okay now that I've
attained wholeness now what and that's
when I met three sages who had not
spoken for over 20 years and I had this
question to them and that was prior to
all this all my
dummy prior to my spiritual journey I
had a large business now all that had
collapsed
I was left and now I had a lot of
challenges the me human reality at that
point in time and my question was here
in the caves
I am I am peaceful downstairs in the
human reality there's war going on what
is the form of yoga I need to be doing
downstairs in the human realities so one
of the so one of the sages said I will
break my silence to speak to you
humanity needs it and it breaks the
silence to speak to me and what every
mentioned was powerful not for the word
but just by the energy field he was
coming from and then he mentioned to me
now we have a gift for you ask us for
anything and we'll give it to you so I
couldn't help but laugh and say you are
not gonna give me what I'm going to ask
you for so what's the point in me asking
for it anyway they said not tomorrow we
gonna walk all the way from South India
all the way up to North India and go
around it we are visiting all the
shrines by walk so anything we think of
we will make it happen
so simply ask so I said okay then give
me the wisdom behind your pillows they
say no no no as for anything else but
not that I said that's the only thing
that's cool
that's the only thing that I seek and
then they said now we understand why we
broke a silence and I would relate my
book mastery of consciousness as the
gift of this meeting where I have 108
sutras each Sutra is to suit a different
state of mind the physical realities
that's one dimension another dimension
is when we talk about yoga or when we
talk about the philosophy of meditation
from a certain perspective it's like
condensing 10,000 hours of of work of
10,000 hours of focus on a single focus
on a single single job all that 10,000
hours of knowing can be brought in and
given an exchange in a moment the grace
we talk about yoga from push and push
and push but we don't talk about yoga
from from full and is grace this is
another dimension that I needed to
convey that grace to is science and then
come the third dimension which is
questions the greatness the the quality
of your answer depends on the question
asked and the quality of your life is
the quality of your questions it's so
exactly to have very good questions yes
so I had I had three very pretty very
being asked me the right questions and
it was a pleasure to answer it from
opposite our perspective for instance if
you ask me what my religion is I would
say I'm liberated today that is the
religion of yoga to be liberated can we
say liberation from and wise from from
the monkey mind Li the mind firstly the
mind da the prisoner of the mind that we
can transcend past the mind in the
limitations in senses that we have here
and then the transcendence like
religious dogma
also exactly exactly from religious
dogma from even our own limits
especially together so rather than yell
liberated we now see the often the most
moved forward by all the philosophers by
all the masters by all enlightened being
by all the poets of the world was not
love it was freedom that's great if we
are free truly free we are loved
yeah if we are loved now we are truly
happy so the sense of freedom is a vital
dimension in our yearning to be free to
be liberated and then then I just I love
how much importance you you put on the
word freedom because freedom is this
thing that we don't even realize that we
we that we kind of breathe and live on a
moment-to-moment basis but but there is
also some oppression that's going on for
people to to want to be free as i as we
look around the world we see we see a
lot of people that aren't free that that
there are financial systems and there
are there are rigged economies and
political systems that are that are
slaving people away away from freedom
and away from their maximal potential
and one of the things that we really
care about doing a lot and we talked
about on the show a lot is how to flip
that [ __ ] on its head so that we can
have much more free world for people and
fix some of the government strategies
that govern us in ways that don't
actually make us free absolutely
and if we want to set us free the first
is not just the mind but the first is
time itself hmm tell us more
so when you say time itself once a day
later lamp and connect to source okay
now come the challenge can you give
yourself a holiday once a week this is
between you and source so for 27 years I
have been holding my Thursday as the day
of fasting and for myself I love acting
and connecting to source a holiday every
week okay once a day once once a day
once a week can you give yourself a
holiday and panic the sauce likewise
observe the new MO and reclaim your
spirit understand that you are the
spirit tell us again about the reaction
to the new moon okay the new moon is
when when we connect to ourselves being
the spirit so this is the time of Lord
Sabha now the full moon is the mind
blossoming this is the time of Lord
Vishnu Lord Vishnu means the awake state
of mind so when you every full moon
bring focus on the blossoming of our
mind bring focus to the joy states of
love in the source connectivity
now if you've done these if you begin to
observe the principles of freedom time
which is like ways that we are riding on
then comes the next which is right the
breath and riding the breath when you
light the lamp once a once once a day if
we the peripheral time is the sunset
time or the sunrise time but in reality
any time as long as the lighted one's
right versus right what you we are doing
is what we are doing is we are beginning
to start beginning to get into the
perpetual Atia of the slam
virtuality of the light and now there is
a ritual I believe that now when every
breath of all is false connected now
we've broken free of the mind itself and
we're connecting to the Eternity in the
breath I love the connection to source
and making it a daily habit whenever we
you know either we feature or we talk to
Yogi's and meditators it's always very
important to continue your practice on a
daily basis the daily habit of breath
and of really you know feeling the
feeling your body in your presence
feeling the transcendence feeling the
future seeing yourself in the future
seeing yourself taking any short-term
goals and achieving your goals and you
know doing the future authoring as well
and I love the idea of taking the one
day a week for connection to source and
just this is this is this is very very
insightful any any other thoughts that
you have that you want to share with us
I have a couple lots of questions for
you yeah okay so when we are meditating
we begin to start understanding that we
are the Sun and not a planet anymore
the planet is the individual existence
going round and round in circles the
mundane life we are living the Sun
simply shines and the realities of
planets go around it in other words the
moment we wake up an inner more Sun
we're in a light now we become the Sun
we radiate we circulate all our reality
and the reality is around us we don't go
around and I think we make the reality
work around ourselves so this would be
meditation disembark and the soil from
shining
so and this is ultimately is why would
we want to do it who have more states of
dying mm-hmm so we said that discipline
to have it more now it's all the path of
God joy is the path and path is the path
is job and that's so much with me oh not
easy I love it and it's just the
beginning we're really just scratching
the surface here there's so much more to
unpack and for us to really be able to
better understand who you are why this
is important to each one of us how to
light the lamp outside every single day
and then have the sunshine from within
us every day take the day every week to
eliminate the oppressive systems that
don't give us the freedom these are all
very important things that you've been
teaching us I want to ask a couple
questions on the way out a couple of
things that come to mind these are some
of the questions that we typically ask
on the show 90g do you think that we are
alone in the cosmos no there's too many
possibilities that exist with a lot of
intelligence that is beyond the human so
yeah we never say that as consider the
universe as infinite infinite infinite
infinite infinite infinity with a
possible billions of possibilities of
life and within all this life here we
are but if we understand that we are the
core of this universe within we are
beginning to tap into all that extra
intelligence that is already there so
for instance the cosmic child has been
depicted in our tradition as the Guru of
all the Guru's Lord Muruga as the six
pointed star who was supposed to
being the grace of the ladies but the
moment we take a mind to all that we are
beginning to start getting into the
realm of of guesswork just guessing but
instead we focus a focus on the core
within ourselves that contains all the
universal intelligence all that energy
field becomes us to shine mm-hmm and
then this does that mean to you that
then we are in a simulation or is this
base reality we can say you know the to
play the two factors happening in the
dual ended in the duality that's working
through and here we are the experience
at the same time we are the experience
or two creating this experience ah so
you guys see what you're doing so even
if it is in fact simulated we are still
the experiencer that is housing as
having the experience true okay okay
that's interesting I think that might be
the first time we've heard that one Ron
that that that that even if it is a
simulation yeah even if it is a
simulation that that we are still the
experiences of the simulation therefore
they can happen concurrently at the same
time well that's what I say
don't I say that haven't I been saying
maybe yeah maybe maybe that's good
that's good we get some fresh cut Ronnie
in there fresh shave fresh haircut
looking clean okay not easy good okay
how about what do you thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world
the most beautiful thing in the world is
to be aligned to our highest doing to be
vibrating as source itself and when you
say to be vibrating a source itself when
we are in the alignment of source or
alignment of a highest purpose aligned
to doing it from the perspective of
having all that flowing through with
inspiration that's when we are the
radiance of the Sun there could be
nothing more beautiful than that and at
at this point everything all of the
universes come to take part in it it's
like when you visualize light and
imagine all the angels dancing around
the light that the angels dancing around
the light itself is life just like while
we are being that epicenter from where
life itself is celebrating around us
that's so well sir I really I really
appreciate how you described the it's
actually very it's so it's so elegant
it's this it's the source tapping into
the source and then that acting as the
Sun that shines that is our full
potential and so we tap into the source
we unlock the Sun the Sun shines and
shines and brighter and bigger and and
and then the the orbit the dance I love
it the orbits the dance the energy that
comes to us and around us yeah this is
really good see when you look at a
planet a planet has a day has its day
the nights but when you attain the
stains of torria the yogic state of mind
it's the Sun it shines no matter what
yes yes so
good we know I her into this we've gone
beyond limits of time gone beyond the
limits of the mind gone beyond the
limits of limit itself now we shine
simply because so is so is we shine
simply because we shine because the Sun
always shines this isn't the planet that
has a dark side of the light side yeah I
love it
shine because to shine and tap into the
source I'm he gee this is so
interestingly connected to everything
that you know what we talk about in here
we love talking about maximizing human
potential and the importance of figuring
out how to tap into the source you've
given us these really good
recommendations the first thing is to
just meditate and that's just simply
taking that breath in a feeling that
source feeling what's transcendent past
your body unleashing that sunlight
within you and knowing that this path
that you're on is this ultimate divinity
within you and go and embark and enjoy
all of the ups and downs all of the
loves and and find freedom find true
absolute freedom and share that with
other people this has been such a
blessing not easy thank you so much for
coming onto the show we greatly
appreciate it brother thank you thank
you thank you it's been such a guy it is
my honor and most important it you know
when we share breath when you share
thought when we share light we are the
same oneness reflecting through each
other so it's time to say it is these
are moments to celebrate a consciousness
celebrate a time of shared breath and
our shared thought and a shared wisdom
and most important the innermost dance
of each renowned the namaste namaste
this shared breath the shared wisdom the
shared experience on this planet
none eg I'm so excited to host you in
person in the studio please do let us
know when you are in sanh
francisco we would love to have you
thank you and a live event to
potentially we'd love to have you we
have lots of important ways to connect
this would be a good show if we did you
Plus maybe a neuroscientist that could
be kind of interesting something like
that yeah yeah we can mix make some
really important feels together like
that everybody thank you so much for
tuning in we really appreciate it if you
guys had a good time please do you know
fallen on eg all of his links are in the
bio please go check out more of his work
it's really important to find that
source find the source let the Sun and
the shine through you and into the world
and and and unlock freedom within
ourselves and within other people be
liberated liberated and thank you
everyone go and share with people share
with them go comment below let us know
your thoughts subscribe join us on
patreon so we can continue supporting
the studio we want to fly money G here
we want to host them in studios so join
us on patreon help us out there thanks
to Ron our producer and director much
love everyone thank you and we'll see
you soon thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]